you just worked with Jamie Foxx he's
someone who's on our hearts right now
have you been in touch with him I was
texting him and just yesterday I talked
to his friend who's like really in touch
with him and yesterday I was like really
freaking out because all the news that
he's getting worse so I was texting
Derek and he's like no no he's
recovering so just like hearing that
he's recovering made me feel so much
better yeah yeah so but I was I was
texting and like but I personally I did
not hear anything back unfortunately so
I'm just praying and my friend yesterday
reached out to me she's like let's pray
together I mean it's it's really crazy
like but all we have in this world is
our health our life so it's very scary
real crane yeah so you spoke with
Jamie's friend and he said that he's
recovering and everything's okay yes
okay that's wonderful to hear I mean
it's so wonderful to hear I actually
could breathe yesterday because I
couldn't stop thinking about him and I
just couldn't yeah it's like he's my
heart yesterday okay okay is there a
message that he wants the world to know
as he's kind of on this health journey I
mean it's actually very wonderful what
he did yesterday he posted on his social
media that like I'm blessed and thank
you for all the love and I just hope
that truly he feels that he's blessed
and everybody is praying for his health
and speedy recovery so I think he's such
a wonderful person he brings so much
light and laughter into this world and I
just hope in times like this he feels it
back that we think about him and we pray
for him when you were working with him
did it seem business as usual he seemed
fine well when I was working yeah when I
was working with him he was like healthy
he's like he has so much energy so
that's why it's very hard to imagine
that he's going through something like
this right now that's why I feel like
you never know but he is healthy he is
full of energy he's like constantly
making jokes and uh I mean he's an
incredible person and he has so much
Vision what he wants to like as an actor
he was giving me lots of creative
freedoms but at the same time he was
very specific what he wanted like if he
was like what you deliver yes yes yes
yes yes I was a little scared of you
just to say at least when the nasty he's
like why were you scared of me I'm nice
I was like yes you are yes you are it is
nice so tonight's a really exciting
night of course we're here to honor John
Ritter and all the amazing work that
they do why was it important that you be
here tonight well I'm always honored to
support such great costs and so many
people are dying from heart diseases and
unfortunately John passed away from this
too and it's so wonderful that you can
you can do a difference in this world so
I'm very happy to be here